Japan deems the following four principles essential in assisting developing countries:
First, the developed countries including Japan...
...must contribute through substantial, new and additional, public and private financing.
Second, we must develop rules that will facilitate international recognition...
...of developing countries' emission reductions.
In particular, those achieved through financial assistance...
...in a measurable, reportable and verifiable manner.
Third, on assistance to developing countries,...
...consideration should be given to innovative mechanisms to be implemented in a predictable manner.
And an international system should be established...
...under the auspices of the UN Climate Change Regime.
This system should facilitate one-stop provision of information on...
...and matching of available bilateral and multilateral financing,...
...while securing transparency and effective utilization of assistance.
Fourth, Japan proposes to establish a framework to promote the transfer of low carbon technologies...
...which ensures the protection of intellectual property rights.